foreign
you've been transparent with me I'll be
transparent with you
I am also recently out of a relationship
but mine was a 18-year marriage with
three children and it ended because of
my anger and my wife had expressed me
many many times zero anger at zero you
can't act in Anger at me at all
and I got to the point where I could
mute myself and catch myself or have her
catch me and shift out of it quite
quickly but there was a moment of
something that happened and I acted in
anger and she said that's it
and
for many years she'd been trying to
share with me that it's it's zero they
can't even can't even start but I didn't
think that was possible I didn't think
that you could not go to anger ever that
seemed unrealistic to me so I didn't try
to find out about that because it seemed
like a myth
and the day after she shared this with
me
I'm surrounded by coaches so I happen to
be talking to a coach world class
and he shared with me said Matt anger is
not a base emotion anger is a cover
for pain
but if you allow yourself because it's
so painful that the brain doesn't want
to experience it so it takes it and
shoves it outward as anger
but all you're doing is taking your own
pain and shoving it on the people around
you so he said I want you right now to
think of what is causing you pain what
about that situation you got angry about
is causing you pain and just share it
with me so I started to think about it
and started to share and all of a sudden
words came out all of a sudden tears
started to come out
and I realized and it was so painful and
I realized oh my god I've never felt
this before I've never actually felt
pain before until now
and immediately I didn't feel anger now
it sucked I hated feeling the pain but I
stayed in it and that was
six seven months ago and I have
purposely not numbed myself in any way
no drugs no alcohol no Comfort Foods
even I've lost 50 pounds in the last six
months because I'm eating so cleanly and
the
the result has been I've sat in that
pain and Tim I have not experienced
anger
I don't think
in that whole time so you want the real
answer
allow yourself to feel pain